[Music]
today's question comes from justin in
michigan i was able to graduate from
college debt-free because my wife and i
worked our butts off and lived on a
delicious diet of ramen rice and beans
i have a new job that i love and we just
discovered we were expecting our first
baby i want to sell my current car for 9
000 and buy a mustang convertible for
9000. i would drive my wife's car during
the winter and keep the mustang under a
tarp we have 42 000 in the bank so i
could pay cash and have a super fun car
but we are looking to get a house in the
next year can we afford this car
what an interesting question from justin
michigan
expecting our first baby okay and
wanting a mustang back rachel to when
you guys had your first baby
yes let's say you had 42 000 in the bank
and winston said hey i really want this
mustang convertible
what's the conversation like at the
cruise household
well
uh i don't know i don't know how that
conversation would go george i think
i mean especially if you have a goal of
wanting a new house i mean it's nine
thousand dollars
you're selling the current one for nine
buying one for now that's what i'm
concerned about isn't it just a switch
then
it is but they're kind of down to one
car he's saying i would drive my wife's
car during the winter and keep the
mustang under a tarp oh so the wife
would have to get a car that's where i
get i get a little hairy there because
baby
are the numbers right james
oh yeah this is an interesting situation
if if the numbers are right and it's an
even trade
i'm just saying i wouldn't do it right
now i would wait till the baby's here
and everything's good yeah
take a beat figure out if you can handle
a one-car situation you know if the
wife's at home we just there's a lot of
unknowns here yeah down to the one car
thing i i mean no i mean justin i would
just i'd pump the brakes literally and
not
could you can you afford the car yes
it's not a question of can we afford the
car no the question is is it a wise
financial decision for your stage of
life
and to me this thing's under a tarp it's
just going to be sitting there for most
of the winter in michigan you're not
going to be driving it as much as you
think you are yeah so i'm waiting just
to give it
a mustang will be there there's a lot of
mustangs to go around
keep keep the two cars figure out what
life is like with the new baby and go
from there what's the car you want what
would be the car you would buy
under a tarp
literally i would never buy a car that
would happen
can i ask such a whatever question about
cars sure don't asking the wrong guy
first of all don't this is gonna be
dangerous
don't convertibles have
like you can get a hard top you can get
a soft top why does it have to be under
a tarp is it because maybe the snow in
michigan is just so much that it that
could be part of it i'm looking at the
the manly man in the booth there's a lot
of manly men in the booth
give us anything they're giving us
nothing they don't even know i got my
that's just i don't know anyways justin
i'm not doing it i'm not saying it's not
it's just a not now it's not hey this is
a dumb idea i'm just saying just wait
till the baby's here see what life is
like and then six months after that if
you still want the mustang get yourself
the mustang get yourself the stang i
hope that helps justin baby life can
just be unpredictable and you don't know
what it's going to be like in the
pregnancy and money and definitely not
in a convertible
in in michigan in michigan but hey
you do you